2020 was the year that for many
normalities stopped the kovid 19
pandemic
meant many factories and offices across
the world closed
commuters stayed at home and airports
were largely empty as the global
air networks were reduced to skeleton
schedules
you might think the resulting drop in
carbon emissions
had a discernible effect on the
environment
it didn't the year which saw the largest
ever wildfires in california
and colorado and global sea levels
rising
was still one of the warmest three years
on record
the data in this report should alarm us
all
2020 was 1.2 degrees celsius hotter
than pre-industrial times we are getting
dangerously close to 1.5 degrees celsius
limit that was set by the scientific
community
we are on the verge of the abyss
so why did the slowdown caused by the
pandemic
not have a more positive effect on the
environment
according to the secretary general of
the world meteorological organization
because the effects were temporary
carbon dioxide levels have been building
up
over many decades last year we had about
seven percent drop in the
emissions because of traffic and
less industrial activities and less
consumption of
energy but since this gas has this
cumulative
nature we haven't seen impact in the
real atmosphere
this grim report the un says is
something every world leader should read
many prime ministers and presidents will
be attending a virtual summit
organized by president biden on earth
day
this thursday the un secretary general
says he wants to hear promises of action
from countries
rather than just more words james bay's
al-jazeera at the united nations